Information over consumption is what a
lot of people think.
They mean when they say information
overload.
And that information over consumption
makes a lot more sense,
right?
We don't say that someone's suffering
from food overload.
It's not like,
you know,
fried chickens are offing themselves
than jumping into deep fryer fryers and
some undead Zombie chicken flies out of
the deep fryer and into our mouths,
uh,
for us to eat that.
Never that hasn't happened to my
knowledge.
And if it does,
well then we're in the middle of the
chicken apocalypse.
And that's problematic.
Sometimes I laugh at my own jokes,
but information over consumption is
really the right frame for us to,
to look at things through.
We have to take responsibility both for
the supply and the demand of information
and our role as a,
as a consumer and a supplier of this
stuff.
In the world of food,
for instance,
we have industrialized agriculture,
right?
And as we industrialize agriculture,
we created large corporations who have a
fiduciary responsibility to produce
cheap and popular calories.
And what that means is that they go,
well,
what is it that people want?
And now we've made it so that you can
have a pizza with everything on it
delivered to your house for $15 and a
half hour made from all kinds of
different things from all kinds of
different places.
This is as much of a feat of science and
my mind is putting a man on the moon if
you really sort of think about what it
takes in order to do that.
And I think the same thing has gone on
with information.
We've industrialized media are media
companies now have a fiduciary
responsibility to produce cheap and
popular information.
And that's led us down the road of Glenn
Beck and Sarah Pailin and Keith
Olbermann and,
and uh,
Rachel maddow who don't really want to
inform us.
They want to affirm us.
They want to tell us what it is that we
want.
I mean,
think about this for a second.
Who wants to hear the truth when they
can hear that they're right.
I certainly don't.
I love being affirmed.
I love being told that I'm right and I
certainly like that a lot more than I
like being informed.
And I think that's a important to
realize when we talk about this supply
and demand problem of blaming the victim
is that we're wired for what was good
for us and not necessarily what is good
for us and our producers are producing
what was good for us but not necessarily
what is good for us.
So I don't want to blame the victim,
but I do want us to start waking up and
realizing that this has a,
we have to have a conscious level of
consumption when it comes to information
and take your information.
Diet is an ethical choice of yours.
So when you're on the Huffington post
looking at,
say the Kardashians and you click on the
Kardashians,
uh,
understand that you are not only reading
that article,
but you're also voting for that article.
You're telling an editor to produce more
content like that at the expense of the
stuff that you didn't click on.
And so we have this sort of rapid
innovation of the tyranny of majority,
if you will.
Because of that,
because we are constantly being given
what it is that we want,
not necessarily what it is that we need.
I think that's vital to understand that
there's a difference between those two
things.
But in the world of food,
right,
if we were only given what we want,
what will we look like?
We'd be what we'd look like,
kind of like what we do today,
which we're,
we're about 35% of Americans are obese.
And I think the same thing's going on
with information.
I don't want people to come to,
to really focus on consuming less.
Uh,
just like,
I think appropriate nutrition shouldn't
be focused on consuming less.
Uh,
it should be about consuming well and
being healthy about your information
consumption.
And,
uh,
that's,
that's where I'd like to see us go.
That's what I'd like to see us do is
start building healthy frameworks for
information consumption.
And sometimes that means reducing it.
Sometimes that means increasing and
sometimes that means subtracting some of
the bad stuff and adding some of it gets
done.
Okay.